signori siamo in periodo halloween
quindi è normale che io faccia un po di
horror
insomma visto che sto facendo solo le
ultime però non non prendere sono molto
contento di fare horror ultimamente fare
una intro normale non ci sono riuscito
pazienza ma un gioco che abbia una
grafica come cristo comanda ce l'abbiamo
non massacro ok
beh trovo un gioco simpatico perché si
vede tutto all'interno di una
videocassetta nei giochi che farci
ultimamente ma posso tornare indietro ma
mi fa piacere chiamava non vedo niente
non vedo niente è il gioco più bui non
si vede nulla
non si vedono vhf cambiare il tipo di
grafica negli usi già così un po meglio
sembrano vedono sempre nulla ma meno un
po meglio la grafica della playstation 1
anno questa grafica la playstation e un
ok che si è meglio questa così vedo un
po sporco demonio cosa è successo cos'è
honor gassman re se c'è una [ __ ]
ragnatela cos'è sono morto un bel gioco
è tornato al desktop proprio staff ha
talmente schifo lo capiscono capisco ti
facciamo ne facesse che bella la
schermata comunque quando la b allora
qua fammi capire se muoio mi riesce al
desktop ogni volta sembra sembra che io
ci muoia
non ho capito cosa era però va bene
porta anche bello che bello allegro suo
gioco c'è una torcia qualcosa che di
minimo sì ma la domanda e rimane c'è se
non è che muoio e l'inizio da zero ogni
volta c'è sempre e non c'ho voglia dire
se non lego le cose in italiano leo si
conoscono ascona nel sotto il letto
karima ho pure ci manca solo questo l
open
allora mi sembra tu e cosa che sto gioco
1 la torcia 2 dove salvare perché posso
tornare al destro con cinque minuti
bella sostanza carina e si chiamano
massa quindi eccolo qui ok per adesso mi
serve il
per salvare poi sono apposto giuro no
dicevo e ultimamente stanno facendo i
giusti produzione non capisco il motivo
che ogni tanto c'è una nuova da dvd un
personaggio horror che va tanto una
volta roseland ma adesso sono le suore
ok l'ohio bella sud ad oggi a good en
plein cosa mi serve a cosa mi serve una
good and clank spiega mi ha capito se
serve saper passare nel punto dove prima
non dobbiamo rivo let's go vedi molto
bene molto bene let's go
poi anche toglierla già che ci sei nuova
personali sarebbe tutto molto più carino
con la musica di teletubbies di
sottofondo
no non è vero mica godo su uguale e lì
ho visto qualcosa a camminare perfetto a
posso lanciare la cosa non sasso ho
lanciato un sasso premier ismi sparito
eccolo lo voglio lo voglio dami sasso
davvero perfetto forse compare la sua
lapam lapidata istantaneamente lo deve
fare 20 rosari per mettersi a posto
lo dico io des dorides a glass windows
live rock di windows live right now
scherzo epico finito malissimo posso
aprirla e smi in chiaro devo proprio
infilarmi di entra vr va bene immagino
che la suora non sia così atletica ad
entrarci dentro quindi un radar ma dai e
non sto capendo ma va bene chi se ne
frega trovato un passaggio sotterraneo
salve è semi spunta qualcuno dei
condotti me ne vado ma che no vabbè ma
di nuovo ci deve essere qualcosa di
diverso qui senza qualcosa di diverso se
c'è qualcosa che non ho visto tipo
eccolo lì non è il bagno dei difensori
sono tornati indietro non è un altro
bagno west ma va bene
sì perché questa roba non c'era
effettivamente va bene simpatico andiamo
giù in toto organo di manichino chi non
lo vuole un organo di manichino sono
strisciato nell'area barche vista che a
quella che ho spento con ricavi giusto
ove è simpatico tutti i pezzi del
manichino sono beh meno male che me
l'hai detto sono tutti questi il coso
nel manichino sta per sé la cassettina
di sangue vabbè molto molto utile grazie
che me l'hai detto adesso mi è cambiata
veramente la vita permesso di pinto
religioso lo vedo che ci gesù non me lo
devi spiegare tutto anche qua addio
senza ovviamente offesa sento veramente
bisogno di andare a farmi un bagno
paperclip è tutto chiuso bene fai te
utilità incredibile di questa stanza
cos'è sta roba martello quanti oggetti
in so già cosa servono
non possono scendere nel salire rimango
qua guarda e devo andare succeso l'acqua
come torno su spacco la tv cosa faccio
ma [ __ ] tua sorella morta sorella
ci stava in alta al sabato e sorella
morte era lì a poco si gioca a cosa ho
giocato cos'era roberto chiesa tu che mi
capisci cos'era sa cosa ho giocato per
un'ora e mezzo spiega mi ho deciso di
dare un'altra possibilità a questa roba
perché voglio vedere se ho buttato
veramente probabilmente si prova per
dare ormai ci siamo qua proviamoci ma
che è un orco demonio tua sorella
sorella in mille è proprio la sua ora ho
fatto una mappa così non mi perdo a
questa è la mappa è ottimo o basta
interferenza è rotto le basta animale ci
prova un'altra volta
ma gesù allora vediamo di fare mi fate
bene l'ultima volta ci provo e comunque
qua c'era l'accendino ora che io ve lo
dico
sono convinto che fosse con l'accendino
eccolo o almeno vedo buon gesù
bambinello dove dove dove è andato prima
dove il bambinello tra l'altro ma si può
spaccare allora sta portano interferenza
mila dove sasso ra qua io ogni volta che
provati dal sasso al vetro ci sono
problemi sempre ciò è fatta di marmi e
ci ho messo una vita a ri rompere sta
roba radar non lo prendo tanto cosa
serve ovviamente serve a spostare la zia
problema è che non sono il proprio
esperto di sta roba preferisco vedere
non vorrei in una cagata ma forse la
prima run era la più semplice in modo
tale che ti che prendessi dimestichezza
coi comandi poi da quella volta lì in
poi diventa difficilissimo cioè ti
spunta ogni tre secondi sulla sua ora
come si chiama quello che è
orso bambino o no ma come i bambini
ma allora senti la seconda volta che lo
vedo ma non mi deve dar fastidio non ho
capito questo band mi aprì per cortesia
che il dottore dove andare proprio lì
dove si è entrato to era lì la parte
dove secondari soprano limite se non è
entrato poco nella porta che mi serviva
quindi obolo da ammazzo te lo giuro
t'ammazzo da macity vekta ammazzo ti
fico una pedata che te la ricordi guarda
era esattamente di su che dovevo andare
mamma mia ma che memoria ram incredibile
allora ora l'altro l'altro pezzo del
manichino che possa infilare autori aqua
sbagliato magari non posso pensare
quadri
ecco lo vedi che serviva le offerte
della carne a cristo va bene prendiamo
le offerte della carne che il cristo
porto tutte dotato pure quello che avevo
in più di così che poi mamma mia e manca
manca così niente italiano braccia tutto
ti regalo per natale ha visto che bravo
o più di così è impossibile
così vi metto mi metto pure io cosa
servono ste robe tra gli ammessi tutte
più di così non posso mettere niente
quindi non ci sia tipo carne nel frigo
un petto di pollo giochi dire ti fa
tornare su adesso che succede
poi apparso qualcosa qua gesù telo messe
e visto di la meglio lasciarlo da solo
la croce è meglio lasciarla da sola si
sa mai che si diverta troppo ma che è o
metti barbara d'urso un ragazzetto delle
robe orribili tipo in faccia perché
tutto chiuso dove vado io vedevo
martellare qualcosa ma non so cosa la
croce no forse con la roccia posso
spaccare il soffitto forse madonna
guarda guarda guarda barabba basta basta
e stato qua basta stop mi warrior iii b
le orribile non capisco il senso non so
perché ci ho giocato
basta ragazzi è stato all your non ho
già detto orribile profilo c'è luogo e
figo non trovo il senso profilo il 6
euro fanno parte dell'oro
ora vi sia piaciuto questa è la denuncia
sacre va bene però vi siate divertiti io
no
un altro discorso niente altri giochi
del genere magari un po più consenso la
prossima volta però non era male dai
però che noi siamo aiuto ragazzi quasi
certamente mi piace anche alla pagina di
vista granché come vidotto notizia se
non sapresti discrete e non ci vediamo
allora subito bene grazie
[Musica]